thanks everybody thanks being off for
the introduction very nice to meet you
Ben
I will talk to you today about our
ongoing work on what we'd like to call
fill heart and robotic economy so it
would be you will see with opportunity
also several results in the field but
primarily I want to relate how fill
robotics can lead to opportunities to
investigate fundamental problems in the
science and systems of the robotics
technology so I will talk a lot about
what we call resilient robotic autonomy
and I would like to think of robotic
systems in concert of an evolution so
when I started doing robotics it was
very difficult to actually make a simple
demo in the lab and I'm not sold I'd
have some right here now but it's really
not that many years of difference and
now you can see robotics more and more
being deployed in the field and the
critical question is what allows the
robotic system to be resilient and if
you think from your perspective for
example us and as a system how you can
deal with every different environment
that you or situation that you have to
deal with it's the fact that you have
robustness you have redundancy and you
have resourceful knees if you can't do
it in the way that you think
you will have to do it you will find
another way to adapt for example if you
walk on an old strain and so on and so
forth
so we want to think in the same fashion
for robotic systems what can make them
essentially resilient in their
autonomous operation since many of you
are students here I want to mention that
I'm sure you study a lot of technical
stuff in engineering and other fields of
science but I won't mention it for
myself my motivation for a body start
already from literature before I was
able to understand basic equations and
this is the guy that essentially tried
to present a good future for the
incorporation of robotics in earth side
so I always put that in my slides it's
kind of a you know motivation so back
into the technical I will discuss today
three topics the case of robotic systems
that operate autonomously in conditions
of sensor degradation and I will explain
the second is in very large scale
deployments so in deployments that the
limit is the battery as opposed to the
car builds of the algorithms or the
sensors and three I will assume and I
will we will impose it in the field
experiments that there is zero tell
operation and zero communications to the
robot this means that there is no way to
recover the robot with our student if he
is around so we will just deploy it and
then hopefully things work otherwise we
actually have a crash and a lot of the
work I'm going to present today and
delayed to some of our activities in the
DARPA subterranean challenge but not
only
if you know the darkest subtree is the
challenge that the dark organized about
robots that going to underground
environments it is over three years the
first year took place and finalized the
competition last August it was up what
was called the tunnel circuit where
robots were deployed in a mind like
underground mind like environment this
year we have to participate in the urban
circuit such as subway infrastructure
over summer we have to go to a cave we
don't know which cave but the cave
network and then in the third year there
is a large competition which is supposed
to be comprehensive and robust have to
go simultaneously into all these three
different types of environments with
three hours of endurance and zero till
operation again right so after five
meters in the introduction to the
competition stage we had no ability to
communicate remotely with the robot so
let's consider all these situations and
let's try to think what can make a robot
autonomous in such conditions so I would
like to think I'm sure you know the
classical block diagram of robotics with
controls the destination path planning
and so forth but good luck that we
discussed together how these different
levels of functionality also interplay
and the typical example you can think is
that a robot that is highly uncertain
should plan more safely and less
opportunistically compared to a robot
that is very certain about its pose and
the map of the environment from super
certain about my map I can fly with
extreme agility if I'm not very certain
for my map then I have to fly more
safely if you have for example a flying
robot that can afford a collision with a
wall again you can fly much more with
agility and much more aggressively if
you have a robot that is very sensitive
to energy collision then again you have
to fly in a very conservative manner so
we want to think the design of the
robotics loops and systems in a
comprehensive manner and accounting for
the interconnection between the loops in
order to make what we call a resilient
data known system so I will go step by
step in this process I will present all
some selected results and they
correspond to results of the last let's
say two or three years of research with
my group so the first thing that I will
mention is what we call sense integrated
multimodal localization and mapping so
think of these conditions as they appear
simultaneously for example in non the
ground mine it is GPS tonight that's
pretty common now in robotics research
it is dark that's still easy to resolve
in a way with a lidar for example
unaffected or with lights on board your
robot it is more interesting filled with
obscure ons such as smoke or dust
I guess you drive and you know that it's
difficult to drive through fog lighter
gets degraded through four cameras get
degraded through fog so it's also
difficult with smoke and with dust they
can be geometrically self-similar this
means that essentially we have no often
lighter is not possible to estimate the
robot pose or the map of the environment
s the point clouds look identical
as the robot navigates consider a super
straight long tunnel it is
simultaneously very narrow and very
large-scale and the good question is how
can you make a robot that is robustly
autonomous in terms of its localization
for example in these conditions and the
main key idea that we want to present is
twofold
a is how you introduce multi modality in
the sense of identifying what are the
modalities that inter combination can
penetrate all such conditions and the
second one is how to fuse these
modalities tightly together on the first
aspect we have introduced and we try to
exploit as much as possible thermal
vision and the main reason is because
long-wave ir has their built to
penetrate most of the common obscure ins
that you will have to deal in an actual
autonomous operation so for example if
you are subject to dust in a super dusty
underground mine as they are very common
and especially if you have your rotors
of your helicopter pushing all the dust
around thermal vision is one key way to
go and overcome the situations but the
problem is that traditional visual
inertia methodology for example will not
be robustly applicable to thermal vision
does we have to innovate about the
method so let me actually start from the
latter recently the last two years we
are working a lot in this environment
such as the one that you see there this
is an underground mine in which my
students have been deploying this robot
in order to explore it in preparation
for these gears DARPA challenge and what
you can see there is that the robot is
flying through a cloud of dust this
means for lighter that the point cloud
is over often included which means that
after registration is not really
possible for visual means that we have a
highly degraded frame because it's full
of dust which essential transient
features and then you can see that in
the figure there I can emphasize this
a bit whereas for example thermal vision
is completely unaffected the problem
however is that here you don't
necessarily have a very strong
environment terms of visual features now
a good property of thermal vision sensor
such as a FLIR tower camera or Boston is
that they provide you a full 16-bit 12
or 14 actually but it's in a 16-bit
world a resolution about the thermal
gradient which means that if you
repurpose your algorithms from the
beginning to account for the full
resolution of thermal gradients inside
the environment and because even if the
temperature is more or less the same as
it is in an underground environment that
is for example 12 file sorry 1200 feet
below the ground and thus temperature is
mostly the same the fact that you have
different materials ground rock water
and Sun support let me see if it is
different thus certain gradients still
exist the key question now is how to
fuse them properly so this is a piece of
work that one of my students has
published last ikura and it relates to
what we call ki ta o ki frame based
thermal inertia odometry it's a
bifurcated structure that on the front
end tries to find the most significant
gradients in the full resolution of the
thermal frame number one number two use
a keyframe to do alignment from the
current frame to previous keyframes that
have been incorporated in a sliding
window over this keyframe Deleuze do
some refinement as it does the alignment
process from the current frame to the
previous keyframes in order to improve a
little bit decimation of the respective
transformation and then we will do
optimization on the back and accounting
also for IMU errors so the front end is
responsible for this typically called
image alignment and point initialization
and also landmark initialization from
frame to the 3d world now a key fact or
thermal vision is also that you have a
process called flat wheel correction
which means that as the sensor
accumulates a lot of noise this actually
happens on normal cameras but it's very
insignificant therefore you don't really
observe it as the sensor accumulate
significant noise it has to block it for
roughly half a second it puts a black
body in front or it calibrates the noise
data and then re-enable standard a
stream back to you which means
practically for robotics that for you
have half a second of loss of data so in
order to robustly
operate in these conditions Aniki
for example a Kalman filter will not
really do an amazing job as opposed to
keyframe
optimization that uses a variety of
keyframes in its back-end it does
marginalization of the keyframe that
you're gonna drop when you have to drop
a keyframe and then the scope Tamizh
ation of the IMU error that in the
reproduction error from the camera so to
put the basic equations together for you
to have an understanding
we the image alignment relates to the
diametric error so it's a direct method
essentially that relates the gradients
that you have in the thermal frame we do
it of course over a scale space as it is
traditional in computer vision we start
from the most part the high-level scale
space in order to go fast and then we've
refined the resolution in the lower
level and then on the cop Tamizh ation
on the back end we depend essentially on
information matrices that scale and
weight the problem between the IMU
errors and the projection errors from
landmarks so we run this in a high
update rate the camera provides us 30
FPS depending on the sensor you use but
the one we have instead of pairs and we
run it actually in the same speed real
time on the robot so of course the key
question in robotics is good yeah does
it work and I would like to show you a
couple of results this is in an
underground mine in Northern Nevada the
April talks are not they don't relate to
the experiment we have to deploy
multiple robots and we align all robust
a common frame therefore the April touch
that's also how Darwin does it in the
beginning of the competition and then
what you see here is the result of KPI
or odometer estimation in comparison
with lighter odometer in mapping in an
environment that essentially lighter can
also work because unless with exception
of this beginning there are not really
many of students and therefore we could
facilitate something like ground truth
in these conditions what you see on the
bottom relates to new features good
features are introduced the green ones
blue ones that are tracked from before
and red ones that are kicked out from
the estimation and then you see of
course the proper alignment between
previous keyframe and the current frame
so this process will continue I will let
the video only play for a little bit of
of a minute but the resulting fact is
that with a very lightweight sensor with
a sensor that does not have influence
from smoke or from dust
and so on so forth disclaimer here if it
is a hot smoke from an active fire
actually this this camera would not
really work per se but there are other
solutions they're a bit more expensive
however you have the ability to estimate
the robot odometry inside an underground
mine and even when for example the
geometry is self-similar so when a
lighter will not work
now the lidar typically you solve a
large percentage of the cases number one
but at the same time you pay a huge
penalty of weight even the most
lightweight 3d ladder like that is
roughly 350 grams number one number two
it still cannot work in the self-similar
geometric situation so we need to add
this robustness into the estimation
process we currently fuse the two
modalities in an ikea fashion
subsequently in a cascade and then we
have current work on a common post-grad
optimization between the different
modalities all together in one single
optimization we also compare our
solution with state-of-the-art methods
in visual individual naradhama ddso from
tu Munich love you a modification to use
thermal data with 16-bit called rodeo
and aquas the latter two from ETH Zurich
and ox is not Imperial with stefano de
nagar and their top methods we don't
want to say that we that we are better
in terms of visual inertia localization
what we indicates that we have a method
that is tailored to thermal energy
localization and the methyls there the
other ones don't fail because they're
bad they fail because they didn't never
had to account for the fact that thermal
data are somehow different compared to
visual information we have deployed this
much more extensively compared to just
the video that I show here so this on
the right is in case of a theatrical
smoke-filled environment that's actually
one of the early pieces of work and the
robot will navigate also an environment
will again go dark and reliable pose
estimation is more than possible so we
have the classical expectation of error
less than 1% as it's typical in visual
nursery localization now applicable
thermal inertia which is unaffected
again from many cases of visual
degradation so I would like you now to
think of the following if we have a
robot that can penetrate conditions of
visual degradation and thus it is more
robust compared to a traditional system
that will merely integrate a visual
camera and name you or a lidar which
will then be subject to all the problems
I highlight in the beginning the second
critical question is what can you do
with it in terms of truly autonomous
exploration of large scale and possibly
geometrically constrained environments
so this is a problem we have been
working over the last years also again I
would like to emphasize what is the
difficulty the difficulty is that you
have a resource constrained robotic
system that has to make a fairly large
map of the environment has to utilize
the information of building them up in
an online process to identify where to
go next
again I highlight that we don't know the
map a priori this means we have no
information for the environment other
than the general bounds like the Delta X
Delta Y Delta said this environment can
be simultaneously very narrow which
means that you cannot simply go fast if
it was an open ending space the solution
is pretty simple we just go fast and we
don't collide so it is not out therefore
we have to avoid every obstacle with
caution and three we have the fact that
we have a difficult situation in terms
of perception thus it is not unlikely
and we have to account for the fact that
our robot might be uncertain in terms of
its estimation process so if we try to
think of these problems all together in
one picture we have tried to propose
three different types of algorithms that
we then combine into a more
comprehensive system of system solution
one relates to accounting for the robot
uncertainty the underlying uncertainty
of the state estimation process into
planning and the obvious example but you
have to think is that if you are in
environment and on the left side is a
white wall in the right side is a future
full wall you yourself will look towards
the right side to understand where you
are right it's always so similarly and
visually identical there is no point to
remember that it will not help you to
remember where you are so similarly
robots should account for visual
features in planning to support its land
support its localization process number
two if everything is also self similar
and something is fairly distinct it
makes sense for the robot vision spend
one more second of sampling data from
the environment they better be spent on
areas that are visually solid where
attention of the robot makes sense to be
spent and third if there are lot of -
are essential in local behaviors the key
question is how can we make a behavior
that allows the robot to sample and
navigate very large scale environments
explore them and especially environments
that have multi branches such as for
example
mine in this presentation I will only
focus really on the first and on the on
the ladder on the third and then I will
also mention a couple of things but
later about some more recent results for
coalition aware exploration and some
learning based methods to compress the
behavior of our clients let me go to the
first so as you know the full problem of
finding where to go accounting for your
estimation properties and so on so forth
is upon DB this means that it's very
complex this means that the practical
solution Tran Cades typically the full
configuration space of the problem and
here we propose a multi objective nest
optimisation scheme that on the first
level the robot in the whatever known
space has explored so far tries to
sample a set of Robo configurations
paths that allowed to explore towards
the unknown space the pink color that
you see there but as it tries to go
there once it identify is the best path
to explore the unknown space given a
certain field of view of a sensor it
then reiterates how should it move
towards this viewpoint inner city
horizon fashion such that the respective
Associated localization uncertainty is
minimized as the robot navigates in the
respective pose so to do that the second
level has to simultaniously account for
the covariance of the robot pose and for
examine the landmarks of the environment
if we refer to a visual inertial
localization solution which we do so by
factorize in the covariance into the
optimality metric an idea that comes
from the theory of optimal experiment
design and we try to resemble possible
alternative trajectories that go to our
viewpoint but identifying the one that
minimized the arriving uncertainty on
the robot so I will show here roughly a
video of how this works this robot
actually the first paper of my lab here
in the US so it explores the unknown
environment as you can see it built the
traditional optimal configuration the
small blue bubbles that you see are the
locations of respective landmarks from
vision and here it has identified to
move forward but instead of going
straight you see the repositions its
orientations you also sit once more time
to move straight to explore forward but
by ad observing as it moves good
features that has identified before
thus the robot maintains that the
associate uncertainty is not exploding
now it is important to highlight that
this is not a global solution so we
cannot provide a global inconsistent map
because we don't actually know them up
the full one and because we are solving
only a part of the full problem that
actually the full puppy problem that we
have to solve but we have to of course
to do it in a real-time fashion so what
you so here's a bit slowed down of
course now again it's accelerated
because it's the robot navigation but
now given this component we can say that
we can plan paths that are aware of the
respective uncertainty of the robot
thus we can explore and try at least
maintain basic consistency of our pose
and of course that means most likely
that the map is also fairly consistent
so this component is something that we
run now at every level of our basic
solutions and therefore you can see this
low level part to be running in all the
other steps I'm gonna highlight and very
recently we are trying to work in this
very large scale of environments so in
underground mind if you have never been
to one it's actually pretty cool seeing
real it's a factory underground is
impressive what humanity builds
sometimes too you know for production
and make money eventually the
underground mind can be multiple miles
long it can be multiple levels across
its structure and can have multiple
branches where the robot has to explore
so if there is for example an
underground sets in rescue scenario
certain people come from top or from a
portal they enter the mine and they have
to navigate this environment to explore
it and identify who they have to save
now for humans is really simple because
we are so capable and so I don't say
intelligent in the intellectual sense
but so capable to an intelligent to
overcome different environmental
conditions and understand how to
navigate super complex environments for
robots is really not the case so trying
to incorporate this capability to a
certain extent of course into robotic
system we propose a two layer structure
at Cana bifurcation between a super fast
efficient local layer and the global
layer that only has to deal with what
should the robot do if it reaches a dead
end therefore exploration cannot
continue should it go to a previous
branch and from there continue the
exploration process so in a basic
schematic way this is an underground
online environment let's say this is
actually a mind that we deployed Edgar
mine in Colorado
let's say the robot has been deployed
from the beginning it's a portal and
it's somewhere in this particular
position in this impart we can sample a
local subspace of the environment for
which we have explored only a part the
one that's behind us and we haven't
explored the area in front of us after
of course the range of the sensor we are
using onboard the system the systems
that we use in this environments
typically incorporate a lighter so they
are fairly long range in this box that
you see in this local configuration
space we can sample some way of
identifying the possible paths of the
robot let's say for the purpose of
discussion this is a graph based search
that was the first way we did it and
then we have some other ways I'm gonna
show a bit later if you sample a graph
of possible robot configurations this
means that inside those you can identify
the possible topologies for navigation
how can the robot navigate in this
explored space but if every node of this
graph is annotated with The Associated
expected exploration gain then you can
actually sorry you can actually think
that in this path we can in this graph
you can find the path that explore most
of the unknown space so we will pick
this path and navigate and explore as
much as we know but it is kind of
evident that it is eventually possible
for the robot to reach a local dead-end
why because it never really knew the
whole map it is therefore if it
navigates a drift and there are some
branches for example to the right it is
possible and most likely orbit will
continue straight because it gives a lot
of exploration gain tentatively and
eventually there is a Denon at this
point the robot must have remembered in
its memory not just the full map which
ends up being of extra Buehler scale
therefore planning in the full map will
become impossible if it's for example a
mile long and you need a decent
resolution this is not something you
want to do to start sampling randomly in
the full map instead as the robot
navigates it identifies locations of the
graph that correspond to branches and
other openings to a known space it
memorized only the specific locations
and also writes down a sparse graph that
allows you to navigate into this
selectively previous locations plus to
home back to the initial position so if
this is the case then we can identify
this branch for example there the
intersection the robot now can
reposition itself
the intersection continues exploration
space as long as there is remaining
endurance on the system and eventually
when the endurance is about to end
trigger and not a homing operation and
return back to home this is really the
type of mission you will consider for a
truly autonomous system you can deploy
it you never deal with it you don't have
communication it comes back it gives you
the data it's kind of you know inspiring
to think that robots can do all their
mission without a single point of human
direction all right let me show a result
of this this is a deployment that we did
in Switzerland in the DARPA project we
work together with our colleagues from
ETH Zurich again there are bot starts
with a simple text more or less this is
the processor you see this the local
graph we sample the graph in the
environment the green one is the
optimized path the robot follows the
path that you see it keep exploring the
environment now this particular video
relates to an area of the mind there the
guns an underground mine there is a dead
end
fairly close and the robot at this point
will identify that has to go backwards
so now we play the video a little bit
too fast because that was an IRA
submission in how to play for one minute
video so eventually it will go backwards
it will keep exploring now a new drift
of the mind it has some cool parts
because we're testing together with the
animal like Hitler protic system from
ETH at some point the robot will go
above animal to fly as the one robot had
stopped for the other robot to do the
process so here's what I'm saying and
eventually at this point the battery is
going down in the rabbit will start
humming automatically to its initial
location and this is the resulting map
that you see from from the mind now we
can actually take the lessons learn from
this process and the key fact that we
observe in doing these operations
relates to two facts first of all speed
is what mostly matters for flying
systems especially if you want to go
into large-scale environments number one
number two it is extremely difficult in
these super narrow settings to ensure
that you will avoid all possible
collisions unless you fly super
conservatively which then contradicts
the basic thing dimension before the
fact that you need to go fast number one
and number two it is also a fact that it
is still expensive
the aliens are trying to say despite the
comes the the bifurcation of local and
global planning it is still fairly
expensive for the robot so this means we
spent a good 300 400 milliseconds for
sampling at 10
their path ahead of us right so it's
selecting a 10-meter path which sounds
okay if there are wood flies with with
low speed but if eventually you don't
push the frontier you want to have
superfast planning so recently we
presented two alternative approaches one
is to utilize the collision color and
robot and then plan based on their
account for the dynamics of the system
and also the effect of possible
collision in terms of the kinetic energy
so you have a mass you have a velocity
from that you can find what kinetic
energy may or may not lead to
significant bump if you're gonna touch
the wall or crush the wall if you want
just an affordable collision and the
second one we try to compress the
behavior of power planner through a
learning framework which is initial
Ghost mutation learning and other guys
have converted to an RL framework that
also counts for collision so this is the
result of the first method try to
highlight this robot that is collision
tolerant is together with some
collaborators and it cut is also a small
light that's a bit of critter where we
placed it now we are repositioning some
things and this is the voxbox
representational you so before the
Cap'n's map from box works and now that
will start going inside this underground
mine and it will explore it with a speed
that was the limit not coming now from
the planner which was very fast but
actually coming from what we thought at
least back then that was a collision
tolerant speed this means a speed that
even if we touch a wall we can survive
which is not very high at the moments
now we have also accelerated a little
bit
so this was one point eight five meters
per second average speed and our goal
eventually is in such underground mines
to go with roughly four meters per
second which may may not sound huge to
you but actually it's a significant
difference compared to what has been
presented in the state of fear so here
we will explore this mind this kind of
straight drift so it's not super
exciting afterwards i'm gonna present a
result from an abandoned mine this is a
complete different experience if you try
to get your robot into an abandoned
place you yourself actually you're not
feeling sure about where you're
navigating and it was a very narrow
place because that's how mines were
built originally so if we play this
video a little bit faster yes here here
we even completely eliminate the need
for it to account for a larger size
compared to itself you know
avoid collisions here we just consider
the exact diameter of the robot and you
will see it will explore this
underground chiller mine as it is called
and at one particular point you will see
it will make a small collision with
environment which is nothing special but
the fact is that that was actually
unintended that was not even planned
from the from the planet to
intentionally collide that was just
happened because the environment was so
small there are some of course
disturbance on the robot even from
itself right from the durability it
generates that was one of the collisions
and the robot then after continuous
exploration which what we try to
highlight here is that this common
thinking between perception planning
controls that runs an embassy on board
and eventually of course proper design
now for what I mentioned about
compressing the behavior and the
previous approach was stealing the
orders of few hundreds of milliseconds
what you see here is in the actual in
the order of 20 milliseconds altogether
and this is a full learn framework
taking a slightly window of point clouds
from the expert finding the fk-ik taking
the path scouring the paths of the
expert the previous plan was considered
the expert for training this solution
and then providing identical more or
less paths such as those of the expert
in in the online operation and again the
idea here is complete neutralization
right so we didn't want to do learning
because it's it's just better if it's a
keyword we actually can compress
model-based behavior into a much more
efficient framework that we can then
deploy in increasingly miniaturized
systems with fairly good robust and so
of course we have to investigate the
robustness of the framework and how
generalizable this but in principle the
basic idea is to compress knowing good
behavior into methods that are extremely
fast to operate online and they actually
rely on much more minimalistic data as
opposed to a full occupancy map we now
only utilize a small window of
observations as the robot navigates now
for generalizability of results what I
would like to just point out here is
that you see the legged robot from any
from eth animal utilizing the same
planner that i mentioned before the
graph based search and exploring the
same underground mine that i show a
result initially they wanted went two
times twenty times faster from real
speed and here the robot will explore of
course the underlying locomotion is
handled from the controller of the robot
as opposed to the high-level planner
right so they're working in
these things are actually hundred from
the low level controller is a
multi-level system is typically robotics
are all right so I try to highlight a
second component that relates to
exploration again the whole idea is
hockey you make a truly autonomous
systems and resilience through
perception in a robust planning I would
like now to give some credit for some
work that has is part of our research
you don't see it in most of our filter
results but it's actually pretty
important in what we try to do before
utilizing this coalition Poland by
design robot we had a variety of
students that try to work on on
collision tolerant control and even
before myself at a pH I worked a lot on
error manipulation or inspection through
contact this was an academic pistol
where we put a student and Michiel his
he was under girl back then so we didn't
want him to do something practical and
useful as he will say for robotics but
we want him to take a robot try to touch
in an environment and instead of just
flying by sliding we want him to do what
kids call the cartwheel so we wanted him
to take the robot and just essentially
walk around the like walk like roll
around the the wall just show that it's
possible and from that essentially you
know if you the best thing that you can
do in academia strain good students
right so that's that's in any case the
most important piece of work we can do
so he took an MPC approach that we had
that's the position control running on
the robotic system and then he used at
reversibility metric to say that you
know what if you give me part of the
world that is super smooth I may as well
slide on it because friction is not
going to be too much and the walls are
okay to slide and if you give me a non
smooth part I can use this kind of flag
flying cartwheel mode in operation so
then the robot will go will establish
contact this was common and known work
from us before so he utilized it and
then it's really not the most dynamic
performance of the world I have to say
it's a weak robot the classical DJI
mattress it does the job and it only has
the shrouds has not a sensor whatsoever
it just uses the south and we are
pushing the wall to make sure that we
maintain contact and then here from the
mesh he knows that it's not actually
possible to keep sliding and he will
start a very slow process of doing this
kind of flying cartwheel mode that we
mentioned before which again I'm saying
it's not something that you want to do
it's not something you have to do for a
real life mission many times in academia
we do we do stuff just because we want
to investigate a problem so this is one
of these categories I'd supposed to
this is mostly investigating what is
possible so again you don't want to do
this flight but it's possible to do this
way all right continuing in the same
principle actually this is this idea of
incorporating collision later allowed us
through proper collaborations to utilize
the system so here actually we're in
California in a mind called a black
diamond mine in Antioch and here
actually we are exploiting the fact that
the robot can collide we were super
excited at the moment we got it
eventually we were so excited that we
cashed but that's that's another fact
and the robot will keep exploring the
underground environment there with a bit
you know higher speed compared to
previous videos we showed all right now
going back to the last aspects the
control aspect of robotics is I discuss
perception planning and I would like to
introduce some ideas about control and
how can this relate to resilience so one
basic idea of resilience of course it
done and see and it done see may mean
that you have more than one systems to
the job now you can you have seen
multiple approaches on multi robot
systems that exist in the world and
there's one you know a team of five
robust and they try to do something
together here as opposed to the
classical approach we have a link system
and this means that there is an actual
mechanical link from one robot to the
other robot which also means that
there's communication between one robot
to the other robot with whatever
bandwidth we want and also means that we
can because we have a feed off their
joined also with encoders in theory also
we haven't tried this yet we can lose
full estimation from one robot and keep
its maintenance post from another robot
either the front or the back or both of
them so we call this area robotic chain
there has been work that relates the
idea we're not the first that's thought
direction they say some good work for a
robot called dragon and essentially we
follow similar concepts but actually
different ways of control and actually
very different goals so our goal here
was to make a reconfigurable system that
can do the things can minimize the cross
section of a big system so you have a
collection of systems the system systems
but the cross section can be still as
small as we want the size of a small
robot and be we can reconfigure the
geometry so as to maximize coverage or
any other need by redistributing the
sensors of the common robotic system so
to work on the control of this robot in
a meaningful manner we distribute the
control every robot runs and so3
controller on board this means that our
deeds handle from any robot individually
and only one robot runs the
control of the full robotic system of
systems the position the control is
actually organized on the link level the
connecting link between the two robots
and the link role of course keys left
uncontrolled but the actual role pto of
every robot remains fully control so
here you see the robot this is a by
contest this is not pranams and so on so
forth but actually challenging the
people are working to make it autonomous
you see the operation it will change
geometry to just go through different
settings either if they're narrow or if
they open it might as well just change
your metering to full width now if you
have such a robot there are a variety of
things that you can do the first one is
you have very good moment applying
capability by rolling the robot this is
how the system is right here also one
robot versus the other robot which means
that it can apply significant moment if
you're going to use for example for
purpose of error manipulation a piece of
work that the student one is he's trying
to do at this point of course you can
fly class well trajectory that's all
school plots that we used to do when
we're doing controls for quadrocopters
and also you can rotate all around
yourself by still point keeping the
centroid of the whole robot at one exact
point right and then just going up or
down so I suppose the class calsilica
that the whole robot has to go around
here you can make a helix and it will it
will come in a minute and the centroid
of course stays at the exact spot the
idea is that we want to open evolve on
the ground so then we can actually
rotate without moving the centroid of
the robot so this process can continue
here we also show that we go up and down
also doesn't really our basic intent so
the key idea that I want to present
altogether to you is that if you
properly do the individual job so
research for example in thermal energy
odometry or research in part planning
for exploration research for uncertainty
our exploration or motor bodies control
and so on and so forth if you
simultaneously not only work on an
individual level but the people that do
this research essentially design every
loop in a manner that accounts for the
limitations and capabilities of each
other for example if perception is going
wrong as factorized from the covariance
planet has to go a little more
conservatively then this means or has to
look towards specific features this
means that you make an increasingly more
robust and resilient autonomous system
so I won't try that again that this was
the basic idea from now on I'm just
going to show some further applications
some previous work of mine
before I I went and I came to the United
States this was a piece of work that we
did actually that again here in the US
that we did with DOA and some colleagues
from Carnegie Mellon and it's about
radiation mapping that's the Hanford
Site I don't know if you know the story
of the Manhattan Project in the United
States and storing all insane nuclear
waste everywhere in the country and
especially in the East Coast so there
are many of these facilities are not
unique and they're storing their nuclear
and eventually especially now as there
are many many years in this is happening
they have to remap them Andrea dent if I
what is the condition there so here we
have a robotic system that does basic
accelerations we showed before but in
fact also incorporates three simulators
that all together allow it the
scintillators essentially counter
radiation towns allow it to map the
environment to map the environment
similans not only in 3d but estimate the
respective disputed radiation field and
what we use for the purpose of
estimation is a Markov random field and
MRF and the robot will simultaneously
estimate the intensity the gradient of
the field s appears intense the gradient
on multiple points it can also propagate
The Associated estimation from the field
forward in other space other than those
visited as it does so it can know which
parts of the field are those that are
not really identified and estimated
properly and from that by understanding
which are the areas that we really don't
know well we know where to go so this is
a piece of work from one of my students
Frank who did this work here in that
these are actual radiation buckets
that's what students have to deal with
and I'm kidding
the radiation officer put the radiation
sources there and the robot just goes
and explores the end Maps you know the
radiation field and simultaneously
anatase the information a 3d model there
is a bit of cheating here we have a 3d
map but actually we do a 2d ready a
disability radiation field estimation
you know forgive us for that the fact is
that we we just have to undertake
something that looked a little more
impressive but actually the radiation
estimation is 2d then the 3d estimation
is is actually annotated with the
respective color so here's the robot in
front of the buckets now it believes
that all the environment is fairly hot
because it only has a measurement before
the buckets it will try to go forward
because any of these points actually
it's equally unknown in terms of
curiosity like where should we go to
explore better the field now it
identifies that there is a you know
essentially a cluster of
high intensity values there now they are
known is again forward it will go
towards the other set of buckets and
eventually it will give you a decent
estimation of the underlying radiation
field according to where the radiation
officer here the proper sent later for
ground truth in our results the results
were fairly accurate do remember the
value but we have it in the paper about
how accurate they were compared to
ground truthing of the radiation
intensity film all right so summarizing
for for the work of my lab here the last
three point five years that we have been
working in the United States I want to
of course credit our sponsors in coitus
afterwards a lot of the work related
mentioned the DARPA ground but not only
we had work previously with mining
companies we of course NSF and other
agencies have funded our work a little
bit of work with NASA we try to work
more in that direction not yet in space
robotics also my personal goal is to put
at least one line of code into space I'm
kidding
and of course previous work that related
to European projects has content or not
directly has contributed in directly
into the research that you saw here I
very importantly going to credit
collaborators eventually in academia the
cool part is that you can work together
and share together code and research so
from ETH from CMU cenobitic operation
that's a company in Berkeley Minnesota
fly ability does necessity to protect
and others that essentially help us into
executing this particular work very
importantly I want to credit of course
my collaborators in my lab postdocs that
are now both actually professors I
should have take this light eventually
engineers PhD candidates areare who did
the work on thermal inertia odometry
tomb that has done most of the work that
you saw in planning their Frank one
Russell nickel and others that are now
in the piece the process Paulo again I
should have take the slide and others
that are essentially working in the lab
and begun the phases like this I want to
indicate why filled robotics is such an
exciting experience this is all from
fill tests they'll upper and they write
up and the bottom right is from DARPA
the other one is in an underground test
in Switzerland what you see them they're
eating Fundy in the underground mine
that's what Swiss people do so that's
also I wasn't there but I missed it
now let's go back to some just two or
three slides of previous work that's the
one that Benoit I was very kind to
mention that's not only personal work to
hell that this was roughly fourteen
people or
during the project and the main pins
these called Phillip hold this wagon
here has graduated now he works in
Switzerland and we put a lot of effort
he put most of the effort of course to
develop Atlantic solar a fixed-wing
aircraft five point six meters in
wingspan six point five kilos in weight
that was able to demonstrate what it's
called perpetual flight and the idea was
that you charge you in the day you keep
flying you cross the night and the
morning comes you can still charge you
can start charging again your batteries
and you have remaining battery enough to
get you through the whole day and then
this can happen again and again and
again so we demonstrated eighty 1.5
hours of continuous flight and this is
the world record for any aircraft below
50 kilos if you know that other systems
that go around the globe and stuff but
this is the world girl for this
particular category of aircrafts and of
course unmanned aircrafts give me the
way the system it has a battery very
similar to the one you have on a Tesla
car there is this very good job in robot
state estimation that was 80 1.5 hours
of estimator working properly controls a
lot of work on system miniaturization
and proper engineering I'm sure you know
px for pixels from ETH back then it was
a little bit more and development many
people have this particular has a lot of
unique software running on it compared
to the main stack that you can take
online it has some distance sensing not
too much because there is not much
payload if you want to do the world
record impressively enough when we start
the calculations it was a limit to do
the thing to when it comes to very early
morning to have remaining battery due to
progress in solar panels flexible pans
and batteries of course we were even a
little bit better than on our initial
calculations we have actually a tool
online about how you can design such a
system so if you want to play around you
can actually enjoy the possible
different designs this system is
actually not the ideal design we stopped
at 5.6 meters because we want it to be
easily hunt lunch but actually if you
can make it a little bit wider you can
have even better properties now again or
in previous work that was collision
tolerant this video doesn't play it
please okay that was a robot that wanted
to indicate physical interaction that's
pretty old worked with myself and in in
student that was doing his semester
project at SL at ETH together with some
work on pushing objects for some crazy
asian the robot I write the name of the
lab and you can actually see something a
bit this is very
work that I'm completely unrelated but
it's pretty impressive from ETH that
they actually use it oh but now to paint
fully a wall they spray it but they
actually would go very close and the
idea came essentially already from back
then that's a habit NPC it has two modes
in contact and in flight and the
controller accounts for the transition
between the most that's traditional MPC
design so I'm not going to really
mention much because I'm sure you have
seen impressive videos with robots
flying plus the video doesn't want to
play so we can keep it but that's just
nonlinear NPC essentially and later we
showed also them can lose non propeller
and keep flying very importantly for
robotics we try to open-source a lot of
what we do at least what we have
confidence that is fairly useful for the
community and what we have time of
course to open-source because open
source takes a little resource and we
have open source planners motor belief
control and other things that you may
want to use in your research more
broadly to close my talk I won't
highlight that our mind and our basic
vision relates what we call resilience
and I think this is a key for making
robots that are truly useful in a
variety of conditions to go away from
task specific design and make a more
generalizable robotic system or robotic
system or systems which also means that
then they can be useful in a variety of
applications either construction
inspection work execution together with
humans either completely lose or side by
side with a human so these are possible
applications I'm going to highlight that
we have a lot of interest into this
underground environment not only for for
just for the DARPA project but I think
also there's a lot of room for space
exploration for example in lava tubes on
Mars there is a lot of room for doing
very important missions such as nuclear
decommissioning and of course you can
take the same technology and extend it
and broadening into further types of
applications and scenarios before I
close because I see many of you are
students I want to highlight that you
know nothing was that will be possible
if we were not putting effort into good
education so education I didn't
understand initially before becoming a
professional but I think now I fairly
and guess why it is so essential so
again the basic idea is that we do
courses bottom fundamental science and
on applied topics such as robotics and
very importantly and I don't know if any
of you is undergraduate we try to
emphasize on starting the research as
soon as possible in the course of doing
your studies and this server that we
will see
put the video we yesterday tested this
ability to go up the stairs and this was
full design from undergrad students and
we like to put them essentially give
them an idea that is a hot topic given
something that we really don't believe
it's necessarily possible but if they
feel that is not possible then they
don't feel they have to deliver so
quickly right then they can think more
fundamentally and try to come up
something with that is very interesting
and fundamentally new we thought that I
want to close my talk I want to thank
you for being here and again I hope you
get the message about our research and
resilient economy I'll be very happy to
answer any possible question yes I think
many there are many that are super
exciting and there there are people such
as taffeta scaramouche and others that
work in Activision that in especially in
event-driven cameras we have a lot of
work because we you see a lot of our
research it relates to obscure unfilled
environments we are trying trying to
cope with polarized vision and there has
been a lot of progress in sensing that
allows you to have polarized sensors
that are very miniaturised which means
that you can use them for example to
penetrate conditions of Fox currents
without the need of even more specific
and even more expense technology such as
the thermal camera so in terms of the
hardware itself yes there are many
topics that are can potentially
influence how about it will work in the
future and of course there is a lot of
effort I think and very a lot of
interest into a cooperating attentive
mekinese very early in the stage of the
robot so if you think how we do robotics
at the moment we try to take all the
information and use it at once to make a
map for example but then eventually you
hit the computational bottleneck you
can't do everything for it you can do it
with a lot of data and you can do it for
big environments and the key is that you
can have a very low-level system on the
camera or I'm very close to the sensor
that selects what is the most important
areas of the scene to process further as
supposed to build what we currently bit
which is a super comprehensive map it's
good if you're doing the inspection in
school if you're going to deliver a
small environment with a high resolution
3d point cloud but it's not what you
want for navigation if I'm gonna
navigate 20 kilometers I don't want
20 kilometers of XYZ points yes thank
you for the great talk I was just
wondering about the approach with the
CNN and so did you try on different
minds and how the approach could be used
it's training one so when the system is
simulation and only one data sets from
one mind and then we used in another
mind so essentially we had very specific
data that we put from non simulated
environments the good thing with range
data as opposed to a camera is that the
ability to use simulated data is
actually fairly straightforward you can
simulate the geometries and then just
afterwards introduce noise on your
sensor with cameras it's much more
difficult to go from simulation to 3d
world but here it was fairly possible
first so what we did we just simulated a
lot of mind environments we actually
used also previous deployments of ours
to have meshes and then we just took
those in in simulation in the Zeebo
number one number two we took some very
op just open models that can identify
like that but has the release models of
some minds I don't know if they exist or
they just release some of those we
download some CAD files online and we
put them also in gazebo and then what we
use is our planner to use this an expert
and then three point clouds the three
point clouds organize and on a two
seconds of previous data so not leaving
the three latest but three disability
over two seconds to allow the robot to
identify that the other is a branch but
maybe this branch looks a bit more large
so I should go in the direction and then
we tried imitation learning framework we
also have incorporated something that's
specific to the minds we encode it eight
cardinal directions so suppose the robot
trying to find where to go in full 360
it has eight cardinal directions it
identifies which direction to pick and
then in that plan SEPA in the emulation
line
and so do you think that it's generally
safer to use lidar data to keep network
planning because usually people use
camera data right yeah well it's I mean
in research if you see what people would
do they will if it's possible to be done
with a camera people will try to do the
command I think it's kind of
straightforward right if it can happen
with a small sensor and the chip sensor
why should we put anything else on the
other hand I don't want to go into this
debate between lighter and camera that
exists all around for some reason the
question is if you want if you need a
lighter in your application for other
purposes such for example you want a
good freedom app then you're going to
operate like that then yeah I think for
in terms of of training if from
simulation to real-world it's much more
easy to simulate accurate they're
lighter versus an actual camera and
actually the data is simply right it's
just a range image whereas the other one
is an instant images color it's it
depends on shadow it depends on the
light conditions lighter is just lighter
unless there is obscure ins is pretty
set forward
yep you guys try just to I to comment
about using cameras I have you guys
threaded all applying structure
promotion like I said I'm not really we
use densified we do this fight with
vision like West West made the pose even
with just purely visual inertial we will
use I first air for example we will
densify them up but a we don't work so
much on on loop closure number one
number two we don't really work so much
intensifying
the navigation through hardware yeah so
we have one speed in front of that and
then I mention in his PhD now he tries
to purely work on what we can do an FPGA
now there are certain things that apart
from the general capabilities there are
certain things that can happen nicely I
speak for example is a good thing that
can happen Iceland on FPGA because
highly parallelizable some things don't
really work very well such as for some
of the background button optimization of
visual inertia we leave that on the on
the softcore arm but we have lying
around their own nephew GA CNN's can
work very well on FPGAs so we try also
with hardware I think eventually because
putting good hardware or special
hardware for a case is one thing that
you can do
I think the key idea is how can we the
purpose actually algorithm to make it
more applicable if you have such
hardware design and that's why we try to
identify what Algrim should we build to
make them optimize from the beginning as
a design for the VGA but with all the
time I'm sure if you work in this I'm
sure you know
there's no more question there's a snake
our speaker thank you
[Applause]